y yo en algún y aterrizamos en bogotá ya
está lista más romeros a la para hablar
de nuestra salud mar bienvenida feliz
jueves ya escuchando advani y vamos a
hablar de los gobiernos del mundo que se
han apresurado en cerrar fronteras con
países del sur de áfrica por esta
variante nueva el commit 19 la omicron
pero esta decisión también ha llevado a
muchas críticas más pues sí la verdad es
que tenemos que sí o sí hablar de estas
restricciones y si realmente hay unos
motivos científicos detrás o no que lo
justifiquen podemos repasarlo con un
mapa que hemos preparado para pues para
poder qué países tienen variantes de
coin y qué países tienen restricciones
de naranja ven los países donde se ha
detectado en la presencia ya de la
variante de kobe 19 omicron tienen que
incluir finlandia que aparece en los
últimos minutos y en rojo los países que
sufren algún tipo de restricción por
parte de otros gobiernos
entonces como ven sólo coincide en dos
en sudáfrica y en botsuana son los
únicos dos países donde efectivamente
hay variante de omicron detectada y que
tienen restricciones los otros países
que ven en rojo en el sur del continente
africano en verdad no se sabe existe o
no la variante pero igual tienen
restricciones de movilidad es entonces
pues eso nos da una seña de que en
verdad estas restricciones no tienen una
base o no se están basando no sobre en
sí pues existe la variante se está
transmitiendo o no porque por ejemplo no
sé si hay alguien que se esté planteando
cerrar fronteras con estados unidos- a
pesar de que ya tiene un caso de omicron
detectado este tipo de políticas han
levantado muchas críticas entre ellas de
las mismas naciones unidas- que se
pronunciaron ayer al respecto
en parte wow lo que es inaceptable es
tener una parte del mundo que es una de
las más vulnerables de la economía
global condena al aislamiento cuando
fueron ellos quienes revelaron la
existencia de una nueva variante
que además ya existían otras partes del
mundo incluido europa parts of the world
including in your wild instruments to
get shift tenemos herramientas para
viajar de manera segura usemos la para
evitar este tipo de apartheid de viajes
es la oms 6-3 del apartheid es
especialmente importante recordar además
raúl que por ejemplo países como países
bajos detectaron que los casos de
variante omicron que tienen circulando
en el país son incluso de antes de que
se identificara oficialmente en
sudáfrica eso que nos dice pues que esa
variante ya estaba circulando en europa
incluso antes de secuenciar se en en
sudáfrica eso fue entre el 19 y el 23 de
noviembre que se encontraron los casos
en países bajos es inevitable que la
ciencia esté unos pasos por detrás al
final de la circulación del virus y eso
también nos indica que probablemente
estas restricciones de estos cierres
ahora mismo ya no tienen mucho sentido
para como medida para contener el virus
pero si tiene unas consecuencias muy
graves sobre los países que están ahora
mismo pues impidiéndoles la movilidad y
es un ejemplo más a veces de esa alarma
es que se mezcla con un cierto pues
racismo en el mundo de la salud alarma
necesaria además marc todavía no se
tienen estudios seguros y como le decía
también una epidemióloga que tuvimos en
nuestro programa el día lunes decía que
pues seguramente se ha comportar como
cualquiera otras variantes así que nada
que preocuparse en euros que estar
tenemos que esperar pendientes tenemos
que esperar hablemos ahora no estoy
británico y de eeuu que ha encontrado
las claves de unos efectos secundarios
de la vacuna de astrazéneca que tan duro
el pegó a la gente pues sí de hecho es
una buena noticia no este año se ha
caracterizado porque hemos acumulado
mucho conocimiento sobre las vacunas y
entre ellos sobre los efectos
secundarios de algunas de ellas
recordemos que la vacuna de oxford tira
de astrazéneca levantó una cierta alarma
por unos coágulos de sangre muy raros
que se encontraron en algunas personas
sobre todo de los rangos más jóvenes de
edad después de recibir
el fármaco eso de hecho ha configurado
cómo se reparten estas vacunas hay
países que ya no la permiten en los
jóvenes menores de 60 años de 50 años y
también desencadenó una investigación en
reino unido y en estados unidos para
identificar el origen de este problema
ahora esa investigación ha dado
resultados y pues lo que sabemos es que
esta vacuna normalmente se ignora se
inocula en el músculo pero si llega a
inocularse en cambio donde afecte un
poco a los vasos sanguíneos y llega al
flujo sanguíneo puede atraer una
proteína que el sistema inmune del
cuerpo confunde con el virus del 19
entonces lanza un montón de anticuerpos
contra esto que considera que es el
virus y así es como se forman estos
coágulos de sangre terminamos esta parte
con un dato y es que estos coágulos
provocaron la muerte de 73 personas por
unos 25 millones de personas que se
inocularon con astrazéneca en reino
unido como para hacernos una idea de que
la proporción es realmente mínima y de
europa a marc nos venimos a el caribe
vamos a la frontera entre haití y
república dominicana porque siguen las
deportaciones de las mujeres embarazadas
pues si es un drama del que ya habíamos
hablado en el y que tenemos que hacerle
seguimiento porque república dominicana
estado por tanto mujeres embarazadas
está deportando a mujeres en estado de
parto desde república dominicana haití
el país de donde provienen la mayoría
entonces la agencia efe recogió algunos
testimonios desde estos centros
hospitalarios que son verdaderamente
sobrecogedores escuchémoslo
fui al hospital de maternidad cuando
estaba en el hospital de maternidad
migración me atrapó
en el hospital me hicieron una cesárea
bajo la supervisión de unas guardias no
me permitieron llevar nada después de la
cesárea tuve eclampsia porque mi presión
arterial era alta cuando llamo a un
médico me dice que no puede hacer nada
por mí dice que me enviaran a casa
raúl estamos hablando entonces de una
mujer embarazada de nueve meses que fue
detenida en el hospital donde se iba a
hacer una revisión médica y que fue
devuelta a haití y otra mujer que la
detuvieron ya habiendo roto aguas esa
mujer de hecho como escuchaban denuncia
haber tenido eclampsia que son como unas
convulsiones que pueden aparecer poco
después del parto y que pueden llevar a
las pacientes al borde del coma la
situación ha llegado a alertar la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos diciendo que esto está
vulnerando el derecho a la salud y
especialmente el derecho a la salud
reproductiva de estas mujeres y
concretamente la denuncia se centra
también en que estén deteniendo a
pacientes en centros hospitalarios algo
que contraviene pues muchos tratados y
muchas decisiones y consensos
internacionales sobre los derechos
humanos qué triste esta noticia mar
muchísimas gracias entonces por toda la
información de hacerlo nos vemos mañana